well the fallout really does continue um
more than two weeks after this interview
aired
and we're now hearing stories about the
palace recruiting diversity chiefs but
we're also hearing more stories coming
out particularly from the cambridge's
camp um we're hearing reports that
prince william
felt quite confronted by the claims that
harry made
in the interview not only the suggestion
of racism within the royal family
something that we saw prince william
rebut really quite firmly when he was
out on that engagement and he was
asked by a reporter is the royal family
racist
but we've also heard through friends of
william who have spoken to
newspapers over here that he really
rejects that suggestion from his brother
that he feels trapped by the firm
he feels trapped by his future role and
you know if you speak to sources close
to william they say this is very much
not the case he's very willing to
embrace his destiny as a future king and
he's very happy
to step up to his responsibilities
certainly it's not the royal family's
intention to have this played out in the
press
the royal family haven't really had a
right to reply we have that very brief
statement from the queen about how she
wanted to take this into
the family he wanted to deal with it as
a private matter
but we are now hearing more out of
williams camp i think the feeling over
here very much
is that we are done with any form of
public
commentary and certainly any sort of
public slang match um is what they want
to avoid clearly we're
we're quite a way off from seeing any
healing of this rift
but i think certainly my understanding
from the cambridge camp is that if
everything is going to be
scrutinized and dissected in the media
then there's really no chance of them
moving on from this so
i would say don't expect to hear any
more certainly from the royal family
this side of the pond post that
interview as far as they're concerned
they are moving on from that they're
taking it in-house they're taking it in
family
and they're dealing with it well i think
you're going to hear less and less about
the current state of the relationship
with the brothers for the simple reason
that every time
something is leaked to the media it sets
those peace talks back
um we do have a deadline approaching uh
come july a statue is going to be
unveiled paying tribute to diana the
princess of wales and what would have
been her 60th birthday
and it's really important to the royal
family but i think particularly to
prince william that
william and harry are there shoulder by
shoulder there is a lot of work clearly
to be done
for this relationship to repair but that
building of trust is obviously something
that's very very important i think
william feels that this is not something
that can be
carried out with a public slang match
and
who's saying what whether or not talks
are productive they want to keep it now
between them so i think we'll hear
probably
rather less about how things are going
between the brothers the real test
will be whether harry is there alongside
his brother in july
you